le problème c'est que les gens en ont
ras-le-bol bon maintenant nous avons
fait une manifestation
elle est dans l'ensemble réussi mais il
s'agit de décider de la suite du
mouvement
à l'heure actuelle il semble que le
consensus se dégage pour tous les
premiers samedis du mois maintenant le
moment entre temps baceux structurelles
tous les sujets c'est l'appauvrissement
par les taxes par les impôts que ce soit
les impôts du type octroi de mer qui
augmente donc que ce soit les impôts
locaux
les taxes foncières mais aussi les la
suppression de l'abattement de 30%
et puis les retraités que l'on
ponctionne les hôpitaux qui vont coûter
de plus en plus cher est de moins en
moins adapté à soigner nos malades voilà
c'est tout ça c'est un problème de vie
en martinique qui se pose réellement et
les martinez cas au moins ont pris
conscience
donc c'est pour cela que nous nous
battons alors évidemment se posera le
problème et c'est pour ça qu'il est une
construction à faire maintenant il se
posera le problème de savoir par quelle
ficelle par quel bout de la ficelle nous
allons commencer mais toujours est il
que ces annonces et un mécontentement
flagrant devant la politique de macron